welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and this video i thought i'd discuss the
mandalorian season 2 plot leaks
how they came about how leaking works in
general and the pros and cons behind it
so yes we're leaking how we leak leaks
it's a topic that i've always kind of
wanted to see on youtube but never
actually seen anyone talking about
so i thought you know this is the heavy
spoilers show will spoil even that for
everyone
i'm a bit of an idiot and i apologize
now one thing that i've always said is
crucial about youtube
it's not just what you cover it's also
what you don't cover
now for example i get sent probably
about five plot leaks a week
um this before the pandemic it was a
hell of a lot more
but you know average five a week and i'm
sure if you've been following the
channel
you'll know that we don't post five plot
leak videos a week
in fact we probably only do about 10 a
year and that's purely because i like to
be quite cautious with things
and not just believe everything because
someone sent me it now if you cast your
mind back to avengers end game
you may remember that in the run-up to
it there were a hell of a lot of plot
leak videos
breaking down rumors and channels just
going wild and making bank
because it seemed like whatever you
talked about with that movie it got
crazy numbers
what do you mean hugh jackman's coming
back this wolverine oh
it was all stuff like that and naturally
people got clickbaited into it
and channels quickly built a hell of a
lot of followers
but when the movie got released uh you
kind of thought you know what these guys
were talking crap
and those channels almost died overnight
and have
i've never really recovered personally i
call it this whole boy who cried wolf
syndrome
that's kind of the name that i've given
to it actually came up with a story
about a boy who cried wolf and uh i'll
tell you
about that another time but basically
what it is is
if you tell people rumors or something's
true
and it turns out not to be doesn't even
matter if down the line you get
something right they're still going to
have in the back of their head
well this person said this so they talk
a lot of crap
so personally i'm quite reserved on how
i talk about plot leaks
i would rather get you know six plot
leak videos a year out
and get all six of them right then do 50
a year
and get six of them right because you're
gonna look like an idiot so
quite cautious and that's why i don't
tend to cover that many plot leaks
now why i chose to cover the mandalorian
season 2 ones
it's purely because after episode 3 i
actually got sent a full breakdown of
both
episode 4 and episode 5. didn't cover
episode four as i'm sure you can tell
because i was very cautious about it but
once it aired
i i went back and read the email and say
oh crap this person
unless they're they're psychic they've
they've predicted all of the plot points
looked at the the plot points for
episode five and thought i can probably
make a video out of that
there's some interesting things in it
like ahsoka's return
the mention of grand admiral thrawn and
of course
baby oda's name who we now have to call
grogu
otherwise the internet will kill us but
i'm still calling baby oda but just
don't tell anyone
so i thought this guy clearly knows what
he's talking about i don't know for
definite
but i made the video now an important
caveat that you have to remember
when making plot leak videos is that you
can't say that you know for definite
that this is true you may have seen my
halloween kills breakdown in which i
talked about how someone had been to a
screening of the movie
they'd sent me a full list of things
that happened and i knew it to be true
because they'd been there
universal blocked the video put a
copyright strike on my channel
and that's why you have to be very
careful with how you would things you
cannot say
i know this to be true you can only say
i think this might happen
which was the case with the mandalorian
episode as i hadn't seen it yet
didn't know this source other than the
fact that they'd sent me episode four
but you know they could still be quite
unreliable and just pulling my leg
as those other four people that week had
been and my wife actually warned me
beforehand paul you could get in
a lot of trouble for this and you always
have to be cautious when approaching
these things because it can really
destroy your relationship with a company
and if you get it wrong you look like a
complete idiot which we'll get into in
just a bit
anyway posted the video out put a
disclaimer at the start of the video
because i didn't want the same situation
that had happened with universal where
they just striked it
i said look if you're from disney and
you you want to discuss these um
please just message me i'm happy to
private the video if it's going to cause
any issues
that night someone actually reached out
from disney to me and they they sent an
email about
midnight and i wake up at 6 30 a.m and
get to work and i think they were in
california so
i had basically this whole day of 6 30
a.m all the way up till
i think it was 5 p.m when they started
work paranoid that my channel was going
to get shut down that was going to get
into a lot of trouble
um i spoke to them it was about a
20-minute conversation
i'm not going to go into the ins and
outs of everything just because it was a
private conversation
but you know what they were i have to
say absolutely lovely people
um really i i all day i was worried
thinking
oh my god i've spoiled this thing
they're gonna hate me
blah blah blah didn't come across like
that at all they were really really nice
and the i'm gonna i'll talk bits about
the conversation so you can kind of
understand what the interaction was
but they basically were saying look the
the reason
that pedro pascal doesn't go on graham
norton and things
is because we're very protective of this
season we don't want people spoiling it
we don't want actors and interviews
potentially slipping
up and letting things go such as
giancarlo esposito who's just announced
that moff gideon's going to be in season
three
so they were very protective over this
and they were more interested in sort of
who had sent me here what the breach was
how i came about this knowledge
um and and more kind of
the the ins and outs of who sent me this
now i didn't give them any names um but
i did kind of tell them where it come
from
and you know what leaks i'd put together
to make
things in this video if it was true
so basically whenever i'm doing a plot
leak video i like to cross-reference
things and don't take everything
completely verbatim
so for that video there were certain
things that i got wrong such as the run
time of the episode which i said was 58
minutes
and there was another source who had
leaked that grogu was actually baby
yoda's name
and i'm still calling them baby odor now
if you cast your mind back to game of
thrones
you may remember that episode in which
the the hand of the king
tywin or was it tyrion i can't remember
that show was so long ago
anyway he he he basically told five
different stories to five different
people
and one of them got back to the queen
and he knew who it was because he told
the one story to the one person so he
could track that down
i kind of worry that my sources are
going to have a similar situation where
they've been told something by
a cast member or a member of the
production team
and they're the only one who knows it so
if i post a video it's going to be
obvious that it's them so i kind of try
and add this information into it
now i i told disney i said look um this
is came from
this place uh this is a thread it was
basically a reddit thread that had
grogu's name on it
and this is the the tweet where i found
out that it was 58 minutes
um and the rest was made up from an
email
i even offered to private the video and
i thought disney were going to take me
up on that straight away
they actually didn't um and they were
really really good about it they said
look
we think the video is fine and we
watched it
they actually said you come up with some
really great theories in it um it's just
more
the the bits of information that have
caused caution for us
so they didn't really want anything
taken down and we were talking about
this on the phone and the star wars
community
you know you guys love to speculate no
matter what gets leaked you're going to
be there day one
and i think you can tell from the the
viewership of the latest episode
that my plot leaks didn't really put a
dent in anyone
you know going to the show they just saw
oh right these leaks were right but you
know
it doesn't you know what no matter what
how how good i describe a plot leak
it never makes up for the real thing and
i'm sure even if you knew that a circle
is going to be an episode
watching it in live action you're like
oh my god i can't believe it
and that is exactly what approached
disney took to it and they were really
kind about it
and i actually had a better experience
with them than i did have with some
other people which we'll talk about in
just a bit but on the whole they were
very kind of forgiving
um and they talked about the production
stuff and it you know what it made me
feel a bit guilty um
because when i do plot leaks you know
i'm doing it for the fans i'm not really
thinking about the people behind the
scenes
but it's clear that you know i'd
these guys disney is a massive
corporation right
billion dollar corporation but the
people who are creating the content
and people like john favreau the actors
the
the other directors the writers they're
really really passionate about what they
do
and the enthusiasm that they bring
really comes across on screen
so when i'm spoiling stuff you know it's
not a good feeling
when you actually start to comprehend
that these guys have put years
of work into this stuff and i just came
along with a microphone in my bedroom
and went blah blah blah this is what
happens
which kind of sucks now that takes me
into the pros and con section
and the pros are very very short
if you get the plot leak right then
people are like right well you got this
plot leak right
but you'll realize over time that
people's memories are very
very short and i leaked movies months
and months ago
got them all right and then when it came
to this it was like
people's brains had reset and they're
like well i don't believe this
you talk a lot of crap don't not
this isn't happening so that's kind of
the cons that we'll get into now the
first con is that you could get a
copyright strike
like universal sent to me where they
just block the video
the other con is it's a pretty crappy
feeling knowing that you've spoiled
this million dollar production just for
the sake of a couple of
youtube views and you're kind of annoyed
you know disney didn't seem that annoyed
with me they were really nice but
personally i'm a paranoid person and
i'll be thinking oh damn
disney hate me because if someone
spoiled something i'd done i would
probably feel the same way
i did reach out to them to make sure
that it was okay to kind of discuss that
i talked with them
in my my episode breakdown they said
that was fine i also said look i'm not
gonna do leaks going forward
um and they said you know what we where
we don't actually mind if you do
some people just want to watch the world
burn which
i'm not even lying that's what they said
so it was a quite a fun interaction but
personally i feel really guilty and like
i've ruined everyone's week
now they obviously know this is a big
security breach so they're going to be
very cautious about sending things out
in future and i did actually reach back
out on my source and say
look mate i had a word with them um
i appreciate you sending me these plot
leaks but i'll just be careful because
you know it's not worth it you losing
your job potentially
over me doing a youtube video don't know
if the person worked for disney but i'm
guessing that they were close because of
the information that they sent so yeah
crappy feeling
disney probably don't think that highly
of me anymore
and a lot of people don't believe me and
i could have gotten a copyright strike
and lost the channel so lots of cons now
we'll go into
more of the the cons on the internet and
that is that star wars fans
are very passionate about stuff and they
think if you're lying or if you've said
something that doesn't make sense
then you're an idiot and i went on
reddit before the episode got posted
and there were just tons and tons of
comments saying this is a load of
garbage heavy spoilers is an idiot he's
talking crap
and it just wasn't a nice feeling seeing
that then the next day i actually woke
up to
a tweet from eckhart's ladder who if
you're in the star wars community i'm
sure you've heard of
does um great videos think he's got over
700 000 subscribers
but he basically said supposed spoilers
out
i don't believe them but it will do a
good job of revealing who has insight to
the show
and who doesn't and i went on to say you
can find this on the channel called
heavy spoilers
to be honest i don't think much of this
dude he unsurprisingly puts spoilers out
on the thumbnails
and ish the day after mando and
presumably other-ish heirs
that would be fine if youtube only sent
out videos to subs
again not nice to wake up to um there
was
so many people replying to his stuff
saying
yeah this guy's an idiot i can't believe
he spoils stuff
which i don't think is massively always
true when it comes to things like the
mandalorian i might put something that
alludes to a spoiler in the
in the thumbnail but it'll never be flat
out exactly what it is
but again some people don't like that at
all for example in our latest
mandalorian video
i put ahsoka in the thumbnail in an
animated version and that is purely
because i thought well
you know they've been talking about
ahsoka for the last two weeks
obviously people are gonna know that
she's coming i'll not put the rosario
dawson picture in this just because
that'll actually spoil things
but you know they know we've been
alluding to ahsoka so if i put her in
them i think
well it might be alluding to her she
might be in the episode it doesn't
completely ruin it but to some people it
will
now i actually reached back out to
eckhart slatter and said fair enough
yeah i shouldn't have put spoilers etc
in the thumb i'm sure you know it's
difficult to talk about the big reveals
with having them in but that didn't
excuse it
hope you enjoy friday cheers and he he
wrote something nice back
um saying you know i saw you did a good
job i respect it and actually enjoy the
videos i watched
but you gotta do better bro which again
i
like leaking stuff i'm thinking like oh
crap like
youtubers hate me disney were lovely but
might not like me that much anymore
reddit hates me thinkers
thinks i'm a liar and i was just getting
so many tweets all day just saying
you're talking crap
now i'm not an innocent party in this at
all which i'm sure you can tell and
you might remember that when the
cultured nerd said that ben
affleck was coming back as batman i was
like what are you talking about man he's
never coming back
he said he's through you idiot so when
he was announcers coming back
first thing i did before even making a
video went and tweeted them
publicly and said look i'm sorry these
guys were right
i was wrong i'm the idiot my bad
unfortunately i haven't had that back so
no one has really came to me or publicly
said
you know what heavy spoilers we we said
something bad about him said he wasn't
genuine
but you know what he was actually
telling the truth so the cons of it are
that you you get some youtube views are
like well
he was right but will not tell him you
get loads of harassment
and that's about it now the problem not
just eckhart's ladder
but the the problem with making
accusations in general that you don't
follow up upon
is that there's so many people in this
thread that think
well he put spoilers in the thumbnails
and his leaks were wrong
they didn't even go and check the leaks
video and then watch the episode to see
if it was right
they just took those two things and
thought oh well you know this guy
is wrong on a number of levels so that's
completely burned my audience out there
from him
it's discredited me quite a lot which
completely sucks
then i think i'm lying and because
there's been no follow-up of like
well you know heavy spoilers was right
there's been no vindication
i've had no apologies from absolutely
anyone
it sucks and i'm gonna get labeled as
this guy who leaked the episode but got
it wrong
and the people who do check i'll say
well he leaked the episode but he spoils
things in his thumbnails because
this guy said so not watching that guy
anyway
so the the pitfalls of it are a lot more
dangerous than saying just doing a post
show
breakdown so that kind of takes me to my
next point which is
i'm probably not going to be doing plot
leaks all that much and i'm sorry
really sorry but you know hopefully
throughout this video i've discussed why
that doesn't mean i won't be doing
rumors or spoilers altogether
what it means is that i simply won't be
doing full episode plot breakdowns so
for example if we were talking about the
mandalorian i would do a video that was
just
i've heard about baby yoda's name and
this is just
the video talking about it and my
reaction to it don't know whether it's
true
i wouldn't sit there and go well the
episode opens on corvus with a socket
and she's got white lightsabers and a
clock on and
she goes to see the magistrate and the
magistrate's like how are you doing
she's wearing a
brown cup it's not going to be that
in-depth but it will still have plot
leaks
and spoilers in and i think that's the
best way to do it without completely
ruining the experience
annoying all these big billion dollar
companies that probably want me dead
and yeah just annoying people on on
youtube and twitter
i'm sure some of you will be like well
that we want to see it all spoiled
but you know you have to keep some of
the mystery there so
top and bottom of it that's kind of how
plot leaks work
why you choose to cover some why you
don't cover others
the pros of it which are you get some
views and people think oh well this guy
knows what he's talking about
the negatives of it which are it's
difficult to get projects given to you
in advance because people pr companies
worry well he might leak it
youtubers think that you suck uh
read it as absolutely hate your guts
think you're a liar
and when you're proven right they don't
say sorry so
again it's this whole kind of big thing
of
well you're pros you've got your one but
your negatives you're going to ruin the
channel
so i'm kind of just going to be very
cautious about things again
hopefully you've enjoyed this video if
you have drop a thumbs up
not the usual kind of thing i do but you
know i thought i'd give a personal
approach to this to kind of let you know
how i know when the leaks are true or
not
hope you enjoyed it take care much love
goodbye peace
you